I'd like to get your opinion on this
because I I don't think it's just like
the IRL space but Al also in like the
adult industry as well you know I I
think recently we've had a huge rise in
like only fans and like let's say
independent adult workers as opposed to
being you know what you experienced when
you signed up by a company what's your
like opinion of the modern kind of like
adult industry and like the entire
landscape now I guess that's system prop
doesn't really work in Japan because
like it's agencies they got power in
Japan more than 50% and that's kind of
if it's 50% that's usually like a
reasonable in Japan oh my [__] up I
know right so the for individual to get
stronger is fine but yeah to have like a
professional filming might be tough
until like you become really famous and
then become frean like some like famous
v v like a famous voice actor they do
the same like because they have to be in
Union so yeah there's no way these like
agencies are going to be looking at all
this money you're racking on only fans
like what do you mean we don't get any
of it yeah that's [__] I mean yeah I
think it's kind of healthy that I think
only fan you have to go is has to go
straight to you right it has to be in
the visual account so yeah uh do you
said you don't think only fans would
work for Japan is that is that right
yeah because agencies want to take money
and that's the system like that's how ad
industry kind of works right you're
definitely going to like see like a
really like popular only fans go and
then the agency is just going to swoop
in try and sweet talk them into like
probably joining that agency and then
you know rob their money for all it's
worth you know this is usually how it
works yeah because like you know I think
it it's good because it brings power to
the individual person definitely but do
you think like the agencies here have
way too much power for that to work I
think so and they don't want you know
what they're going to do instead
right they could probably like I don't
know editors like I don't know how yeah
I guess you have to give them some roles
instead yeah I heard some agencies just
also kept the money like you didn't pay
out I heard that that's pretty it
happens or like they would give them
they'd pay them out but maybe the amount
they were paying them wasn't as much as
they should have been paid it's very
weird I mean it kind of sucks the money
has to go through the agent a lot of the
times so they get to be for Freelancers
they just half the percent half the
money anyway if you if they know like
you're freelancer they're not going to
pay you the same amount like they just
give you the half because that's enough
because otherwise you just get the same
amount anyway so yeah I just think as
well like maybe I don't know this is
from how I see it maybe but like
compared to the West I feel like a lot
of Japanese like people especially like
young people like I don't think they
understand maybe the importance of like
entrepreneurship as much as like Western
people like they don't see it as a
viable option I think like they they
probably see it as like more of a pipe
dream whereas like I think a lot of
people just think to themselves I mean I
could take the hard route and you know
pursue entrepreneurship and re reap all
the benefit for myself but it's way
easier for me to just join an agency and
just sacrifice some of the money you
know I think Japan will get there I
think Japan will get there for sure I
think there is I I think companies in
Japan have been generally have been very
solid for very long time so people have
no reason not to go independently cuz if
you were part of a company they would
take care of you but I think as as the
Modern Age we're seeing Japan's kind of
struggling a bit and I think also it's
not going as well and companies are
letting go of people I think in as well
like the the whole like name value thing
to a company is so much more important
than the JN thing yeah like Johnny for
instance right it's like people are
still [__] signing off for Johnny's
even after all this [__] explain what
Johnny is to so yeah so Johnny's is like
this massive like one of the biggest
Idol uh agencies boy Idol agency in
Japan that's been around since like what
this recognized in English now because
of that well the infamous it's it's
horrible horrible incident
uh by uh somebody who already passed
away but he was a CEO a top person found
he was Johnny yeah Johnny so the company
name is Johnny Mr Johnny Mr Johnny yeah
so he was like after he passed away
there was a bunch of [__] that was
revealed that he was doing a lot of like
sexual misconduct on younger boys
hundreds though it was like there was
more and more keep coming because now
that they can say because he was so
strong so he was so powerful if you
voice that you know you're not going to
be hard like what is he going to do he's
already dead so now they're coming out
about it but like that's the thing like
the the but even after all of that news
went public in Japan the just the pure
name value and the fact that for the
longest time Johnny was like the gateway
to getting into the male Idol industry
people are still like joining Johnny to
hopefully become a male Idol just
because they're like well this is the
thing I need to do that PR was such a
nightmare they changed the name to smile
up yeah smile up like you smile right
now I can't imagine you just have all of
this horrible [__] happen you're like
guys we should name it to smile cuz
we're on the other smile we need smile
what we need right now is
smile we need right now well I I heard
as well again I this is all what
anecdotal but I heard that the agencies
generally are very powerful in Japan
because you know if the uh the the TV or
whatever any anyone who needs Talent or
the deals right yeah they like oh if you
don't do what the agency asks a lot of
the time they like well no talent for
you to work with on your variety shows
or no Talent when I was in the industry
like any adult professional girls uh if
they want to make more money they have
to do kind of shady work like Papa KATU
you know it's freetly criminal but they
try to make it sound want explain what
Papa cats is so it's basically like a
prostitution I guess if instead of doing
professionally you just I don't know
find somebody on the Internet or you you
know somebody who knows somebody um yeah
if you sleep with them I guess you get
good basically it's basically sugar
daddying sugar daddy could use your
sugar daddy this rich guy for us and
we'll take we'll take
50% the crazy thing is not just
actresses but it's been kind of popular
things to do for the colage students or
who want to pay tuition or maybe want
some Gucci bag or something I mean if
it's consensual and the person has
decided and then they they both want to
do it but if an agent is pushing you
into it I think okay what the [__] is
going on here what the hell yeah that's
pretty [__] if agencies get into they
definitely get arrested because you're
not
supposed but if it's just individual I
guess like like you said you're not
going to get arrested you might get I
don't know is is it kind of weird yeah
but hey [__] it if you're not hurting
anyone things could go south very
quickly in situations like that you know
so it's always scary to do well it makes
me wonder if there is an interest from a
Japanese audience because like for from
like a western perspective it almost
feels like if a person was with an
agency then you know they're they're
part of the corporation you know but if
there's if they have like if they're an
independent whatever content creator
whatever even if it's like whatever
industry they're in it almost feels more
like intimate you know it almost feels
like oh yeah you you get to actually
support this person directly and I'm not
sure if there's just a different
mentality with Japanese audiences
especially with you know the out
industry in the idol industry I I'm not
too sure I still I don't think they look
that deeply into kind of stuff like
maybe you know maybe like fans of like
you know idols and stuff like that look
at like say someone who is in Johnny's
and someone else who is independent and
they probably know that there's a
difference but I don't think they're
letting that purely dictate whether I
should be more parasocial with one or
the other if they find out like you are
the streamer or the idol is dating
somebody that changes it oh agency or
not your fault especially with girl I
guess especially the female Idol like oh
now you got a boy so maybe you don't
need my support like you get financial
supported by your boy anyway like that's
kind of mentality the wildest Story I
Heard recently was the story about the
Japanese weather woman oh yeah the Tenn
player which like you know Idols I can
understand but like the fact that this
the fact that this extended to a weather
girl which yeah it sounds weird when you
say weather girl but then when you when
you hear them more the story you're like
oh no no they weren't making weather
girls they were making Idols who to tell
you the weather yeah it's like she
cosplay tells the weather it should have
been me godamn
it
also oh of course oh well you know a l
okay of course na
know's got too much
information she is she guess her fans
were just more devastated because I
think she was not praying I don't know
how genuine her talk was about it
because she's not finding anybody or
she's completely alone she doesn't get a
boy and turns out get a voice yeah I
mean it it was it's so weird that you
know they they've tried to promote I
guess I I don't know I don't know if
they were really trying to make a
Weather Channel or if they were trying
to make something else but uh I mean
whatever it was it [__] worked listen
I I don't know any other weather
channels that sell merchandise of the
weather woman all right oh I saw the
weather woman on somebody's
itasha wow yeah so so if you don't know
the full story I I believe this like
Channel I don't know if it's like News
Channel the whole network but they made
it's a 24-hour News Channel yeah okay
it's a 24-hour News Channel they made a
group of women be like weather girls and
uh that's how they kind of like promoted
the weather I guess half the time half
the time it would kind of be almost like
a podcast radio show where like she
would like read like letters that she
received from like fans or like people
who watch the show just like people out
and about being like Oh today I really
enjoyed the weather you know all thanks
to you telling me about it by the way
thank you you know and and like she
would just kind of like talk about it
you know in between like the the hourly
weather updates or whatever it was and I
think like the way that that show was
structured just made it like parasocial
bait like to the point where it's like
oh she's cute and I get a chance for her
to read my letter yeah like that's that
means I'm in yeah and the fact that they
had like Mee and greets and all that
[__] go to conventions and stuff yeah go
to conventions and uh you know yeah sell
out shows that's each country has their
own appeal of weather people you know
Japan's cute idols and I think colia
when you see their weather women you're
like oh oh this is very different yeah
and then in the UK we have just
60-year-old men or women who are like
it's raining again
yeah weather girl tend to be kind of say
so look like oh she's like completely
looking like her 20 years old virgin but
but I think that's why yeah I think
that's why like when it was revealed
that she was in a relationship everyone
was just like what do you mean she's not
a virgin sheing with somebody what the
[__] very successful C Gooding I love
the I just love the entire Arc of how
like fans found out so so I believe the
entire Arc was uh she was taking some
time off work and people would thought
oh why why is she so like why is she
taking this much time off work people
don't take time off work yeah yeah and
so they thought she must have been going
going on a holiday or something like
that but she was I guess like she was
seen on television in England in
Wimbledon she was yeah yeah yeah she was
the seats that are normally reserve for
family or friends of the players yeah
and there was one Japanese player there
and he she was in the friends and family
seats of wi and everyone's just like no
no no maybe she's a friend of a friend
who knows the good
person maybe she's related to the tennis
player I don't know sh the deal was her
mom was there with her like oh no no why
would her mom be there for the
no makes sense but imagine imagine being
the fan who just happened to [__]
tune into that wimbl match like not
expecting anything just be like you know
what I I just want to support my boy you
know let's go Japan pans over and just
you get your heart broken it's like what
the [__] I wasn't expecting this today
I'll never watch another weather
forecast again never watching tennis
again I have a very vague general
question